un gusto raúl estar en el programa mira
la primera consecuencia que hay es que
la administración trump
a propósito dirigida por un presidente
que fue el líder de los sediciosos e
insurreccional es que aceptaron el
capitolio y ha querido cambiar a última
hora la imagen oficial por la cual eeuu
mira a cuba se había dicho con la
administración que cubra a los lados de
los derechos humanos el país con
problemas en términos democráticos pero
desde la administración obama no se
había definido a cuba como una amenaza a
la seguridad nacional de los eeuu
entonces la primera consecuencia que hay
es que la gran potencia del primer país
del mundo define a cuba- arbitrariamente
como una amenaza a la seguridad nacional
de los eeuu esto trae como consecuencia
la persecución mayor aún porque ya de
verdad que las sanciones son casi el 98
por ciento en el 98 por ciento de lo que
es posible en relación al google
hay una persecución mayor para las
transacciones financieras y comerciales
de cuba con terceros países algo que en
este momento es bastante importante por
la política de reforma económica que
como así ha propuesto activar o acelerar
a partir del primero de enero conduce a
brújula reforma comunitaria cic
profesores podrán o vayan dar nuevamente
un giro de 180 grados en estas
relaciones que augura el futuro de las
relaciones entre washington y la habana
yo creo que esto es un un pataleo última
obra y el el presidente electo joe valle
ha dicho el tanto él como la
vicepresidenta canal a jarvis de que hay
un propósito de darle un giro a la
política hacia cuba y de traerla hasta
el punto donde lo había dejado el
presidente obama yo creo que es que no
hay ni razones de política interna el
puesto que el voto en la florida no fue
a favor de la administración la
administración no le debe nada a la base
cubanoamericana de derecha ni razones de
política exterior más bien de policía y
esther yo creo que hay que pensar es que
sea desprestigiado un instrumento
eficiente de eeuu para comunicarle a sus
aliados y a otros aquellos países que
están envuelto en el terrorismo esto se
desprestigia cuando se usa la lista
simple diariamente para poner allí a
aquel que no le guste hacer un apunte
o aquellos que votaron por ellos
en el sur de los olvido profesor nuevas
leves gracias por su tiempo por estar
aquí con nosotros en france 24 feliz
noche